anyway let's um let's play another game
mmm the random challenge something about
biceps but misspelled oh this is rated
let's play a London which is rating a
YouTube channel I even mean it's like
when you add like when you end a twit
stream and then you just send all your
viewers to a YouTube channel it doesn't
quite work like that though okay London
time I'll see if my opponent wants to go
down any of these lines I just showed
oh thanks for the comments
one hot Scottie Oh CC fives already a
sign that maybe they're I guess I could
go for either in line well that's so
funny
it's not I have to reveal my preparation
what to do against this but do they do
they remember the new order Oh II six so
e six I don't think is um is a great
move here because it blocks in the
bishop and there's all these lines where
the bishop should develop before e6 I
know Bishop d6 is coming there's an idea
don't know if it actually works oh well
let's just play normally actually I
shouldn't be thinking here let's play c3
no let's wait another three
it's weird like I don't think I've ever
had this position after e61 before so
pulling confuse me in sums in regard
this gonna actually transpose though if
knight c6 c3 okay nevermind
we could have transposed into something
by Bishop g3o daus Aldo setting setting
their be chest name hmm
I played dice although I think the
previous stream remember correctly mmm
I challenged um deep Trojan let's play
the London g5 line I will play black I'm
I'm kind of scared of that line
it's such a cool line though thanks for
yeah thanks for bringing up the question
I feel like I need to do preparation
before I like I need to learn how to
swim before I throw myself into the deep
end and drowned
I'd probably learn how the tread water I
don't know you still plan on making
video about tonight's attack oh yeah
maybe so I get that question all the
time I've held off I don't know why it
takes a lot more energy actually to like
record specific like analysis videos for
YouTube then just to livestream well but
maybe I'll do a two night's attack video
when I hit a hundred thousand
subscribers I get that question all the
time though cuz my most they my most
viewed YouTube video I mentioned I
mentioned something about like making a
video about the two nights attack I
never got around to it but still fun to
play on stream occasionally okay this is
this is a very nice London setup where
black block can no longer achieve 94 was
I have too many pieces controlling e4
and I was actually a little bit
expecting busy basics here which may
have been like a better decision
positionally because now this Bishop is
very nice and this Bishop is not not
such a great piece
I'm getting kind of a classic what do we
call this they call this a Pillsbury
attack or basically Pillsbury attack is
is a set up with f/4 and lots of fun
things happen yeah sorry again if I miss
in comments I changed my color to white
I know what that means
I really don't know if that means piggy
bank I think you can't your are able to
change the color of your username on
Twitch I don't know if that's what
you're referring to this opening it's
called London but this specific I
learned this from LA from coast jet
Kubek ski we had played some tournament
together in Romania and he was
explaining so I play the game where I
use this kind of strategy
I didn't know it was called the
Pillsbury attack so there's a few ideas
f5 is a resource pitch of each for I'd
like f5 just trying to damage us this
pawn chain wait did I missed I miss
Bishop oh man oh that's so bad I missed
a simple tactic I've shown the so mean
so many times and now I have it again
but it's not ethical because I someone
who told me in the chat
I'm sorry I'm banned from playing this
move I mean this shouldn't still be a
good position thing on d7 well let's
just take here box is gonna have
weaknesses yeah and this should the win
material ig6 takes g3 oh then I take on
e6 Intermezzo okay yeah this is nice
I found a different way to win a pawn
queen h 5 h 5 would be would be a bow
test gambit now it's not the time to
gambit ooh a lock some big trouble
cuz the bishop is on T 3 it's gonna be
some windmill and discovered check up
Owens trying to probably trying to take
my Knights illegally maybe
yeah like King h8 and then Knight g6
back and then here and I mean mine I
can't really take any more things over
me there's some nice mates vice mother
made in the end maybe I do
oh that's so funny don't resign opponent
play it out
I think it's Force mate and like there's
two there's two of these windmill ideas
so the line just to show is King h8
night g6 King each 795 King h8 Knight f7
King g8 I take the Queen King has to go
back here I have returned to f7 King
goes back to g8 and I takes h6 King h8
and then Queen g8 and whatever it takes
that
Knight f7 is basically smothering me
because my vision controls h7 that's so
beautiful it's gonna happen too
unless it doesn't happen because Black
has three legal moves in this position
but do it do this for the fans do this
for the YouTube people do it do it
no can I still make it work maybe I can
I don't know hmm mmm
I'm so disappointed now I wanted to like
beautiful smother meat and now my dreams
are broken I mean this is still working
oh maybe you might other night comes in
it might still work I mean okay blocks
and I have a lot of options here and put
this is probably not the best way to
play I just wanted a youtube video
called like windmills smother means okay
I think it works here I think it works
so this is double check
well it's dry Rose the windmill smother
means so nigh g5 King h8 I hear the king
has to hear there's all these discovered
checks King goes back my check King has
to go back here and check though this is
all forcing and then King here and Queen
g8 here and then meat I don't know if
there's a simpler approach but this is
this should be good enough
check my my thing just dying but that's
okay check yeah the windmill continues
King f8 so legal cuz i rook don't resign
don't resign yeah I mean here coming oh
it's so beautiful
let's go the windmill smother means it's
some some people will probably
like are you it's not smothering me
because there's no pond then it's close
enough I'm sure I mean at like at that
point of arrow drawing there were
probably a lot of winds but it's nice to
finish a game like that okay you two
people thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it hope you're inspiring and
subscribe and I'll see you in the future
and twitch at twitch chat is actually
saying hi to YouTube look at the twitch
chat
look look say hi back